now that we have our collection of
components our favorite batteries and
resistors we can start to assemble these
into some circuits
and here's a circuit shown here has a
battery
and it has three resistors in a
configuration that's called a
series resistor configuration series
resistors is a familiar pattern and what
you're looking for
is resistors that are connected head to
tail to head to tail so these three
resistors are in series because
they're succession of nodes are all
connected
one after the other so that's what
that's the pattern that tells you this
is a series resistor connection
so we're going to label these our
resistors here we'll call this r1
r2
and r3
and we'll label this as v
and the unknown in this is what is the
current that's flowing here that's what
we want to know we know v we want to
know i
now one thing we know about i is i flows
down into the resistor r1
all of the current comes out of the
other end of resistor r1 because it has
to it can't pile up inside there
all that goes into here
and all that comes out of r3
and i returns to
the place it came from which is the
battery
so that's a characteristic of
of
series resistors is in a series
configuration
is they are head to tail
and that means
that all the components all the
resistors
share
the same current
current
that's that's the key thing
the thing that we don't know that's
different between each resistors
is the the voltage here
and the voltage here
let's call that
v1 this is v2
plus
minus
and this is v3
plus
minus so in general if these resistors
are different values
because they have the same current going
through them ohm's law tells us these
voltages will all be different
so the question i want to answer with
series resistors is could i replace all
three of these
with a single resistor that caused the
same current to flow that's that's the
question we have on the table right now
so we make some observations we have
ohm's law our friend ohm's law
and we know that means
v equals i times r
for any resistor that sets the ratio of
voltage to current
and there's another thing we know about
this which is that v3
plus v2
plus v1 those are the voltages across
each resistor those three voltages have
to add up to this voltage because of the
way the wires are connected
so
the main voltage from the battery
equals
v1
plus v2
plus
v3
we know that's for sure and now what
we're going to do is we're going to
write ohm's law
for each of these individual resistors
v1 equals
i
and i is the same for everybody
times
r1
v2
this voltage here
equals i
times r2
and v3
equals
i times
r3 now you can see if i had four or five
or six resistors i would have four or
five or six equations just like this for
each resistor that was in series
so now what i'm going to do is
substitute these voltages into here and
then we'll make an observation so let's
do that substitution
i can say
v
equals
i r1
plus
i
r2
plus
i
r3
and because it's the same i on every
resistor i can write v
equals i i'm going to factor out the i
r 1
plus r 2
plus r 3.
now what i want to do is take a moment
here and compare this expression
to
this one here the original ohm's law
right there's ohm's law so we have v
equals i some current times some
resistor
i can come up with a resistor value
a single resistor that would give me the
same ohm's law
and that is going to be called
draw let's draw it over here
here's our battery
and i'm going to say there's a resistor
that i can draw here
r series
that's equivalent
to the three resistors here and it's
equivalent in the sense that
it makes i flow here that's what we mean
by equivalent
so in our
case
to get the same current to flow there i
would say
v equals
i
times
r series
in which case what i've done is i've
said that our series
is what is the sum of these three things
r1
plus r2
plus r3
this is how we think about series
resistors we can replace a set of series
resistors
with a single resistor that's equivalent
to it
if we
add the resistors up let's just do a
really fast example to see how this
works i'm going to move the screen
here's an example with three resistors
i've labeled them 100 ohms 50 ohms and
150 ohms and what i want to know is the
current here and we'll put in a voltage
let's say it's 1.5 volts
just a single small battery
so what is
what is the equivalent resistance here
one way to figure this out and to
simplify the circuit is to replace
all three of those resistors with a
series resistor
rs
and that is as we said here is the sum
so it's 100
plus 50
plus 150
and that adds up to 300 ohms
so that's the value of the equivalent
series resistor right here and if i want
to calculate the current i
equals
v over r
and the k this case it's r series
and that equals 1.5
divided by
300
and if i do my calculations right
that comes out to
.005
amperes
or
an easier way to say it is 5
milliamps
milliamperes
so that's i
and now that i know i i can go ahead and
i can calculate
the voltage at each point
across each resistor because i know i i
know r
i can calculate v
so v1
v1 which is
the voltage across that resistor
v1 equals
i
r1 as we said before
so it's 5 milliamps
times 100 ohms
0.5
volts
let's do it for the other one v2
equals i same i this time times r2
5 milliamps
times 1 times 50 ohms
and that equals
0.25
volts
and finally we do v3
this is plus
minus v
3
and that equals
the same current again
times
150 ohms
which is equal to
0.75 volts
so we've solved
the voltage and the current on every
resistor so this circuit is completely
solved and let's do one final check
let's add this up
five five
is zero
carry the one six 6
7 8
15
1.5 volts and that's very handy because
that is the same as that so indeed the
voltages across the resistors did add up
to
the full battery that was applied
there's one more thing i want to point
out here's an example of some series
resistors
that's a familiar pattern and you'll say
oh those are series resistors now be
careful because if
there's a wire here going off and
there's doing this or there's a wire
here
connected to this node here
this still looks like they're in series
but there might be current flowing in
these branches here
if there's
current flowing out anywhere along a
series branch
anywhere along what looks like a series
branch
then
this eye
may or may not be the same as this eye
and it might not be the same as this
so you got to be careful here if you see
branches going off your series resistors
these are not in series unless
these are zero current
if that's zero current and if that is
zero current
then you can consider these in series
so that's just something to be careful
of when you
are looking at a circuit and you see
things that look like they're in series
but they have little branches coming off
so a little warning there
so that's our series resistors if you
have resistors in series you add them up
to get an equivalent resistance